[Música]
en septiembre de 2019 en parís
recordemos que fue antes del hobbit
nadie se espera semejante sorpresa
caminando tranquilamente por una
pasarela elevada como en los años 80
unas siluetas espartanas darán paso a
una explosión de colores lo clásico se
mezcla con no barroco austeridad con la
potencia el poeta poste con alta postura
habrá que esperar al final del desfile
para entender esta función el belga dirk
van noten ha invitado a la iglesia no
cristian lakua a colaborar en una
colección y es una pura maravilla las
colaboraciones las colas están de moda
estos días mezclan alegremente marcas de
moda visiones artísticas mentes
creativas de todo tipo la extensión del
fenómeno comenzó a finales del siglo 20
principios del siglo 21 algunos
historiadores incluso los echan
precisamente en 1999 cuando la joven
marca neoyorquina su prima que no tenía
los conocimientos necesarios para
fabricar zapatillas se dirigió al
fabricante de zapatillas de skate y
xesús el éxito es inmediato como un
relámpago las colaboraciones le prenden
fuego a la moda en primer lugar me gusta
mencionar una marca que considero un
caso de escuela en su colaboración con
ralph simon una de las campañas más
recientes de la marca aborda la noción
de novena de alguna relevancia para
decir nuevos al mismo tiempo siempre hay
algo nuevo en el sentido de que un
fenómeno que ya ha ido se representa en
un contexto que es diferente por lo
tanto nuestro presente y eso es un
aspecto novedoso es decir en el momento
en que todo se vuelve diferente todo se
convierte en un punto de vista
expresivas todo se convierte en una
reivindicación de la identidad renunciar
a la propia identidad específica como de
mauro creativo asociarse liberarse
prada y ralph simon son dos de los
nombres más importantes del prêt à
porter y ambos representan la vanguardia
en cierto sentido si en un momento
determinado de su historia para los
ahora juntos y que ambos renuncien a sus
firmas como una firma de las colecciones
no deja de ser interesante de colección
se casó en abril de 2021
nueva sorpresa dos marcas emblemáticas
del grupo de lujo que bing se unen para
una colección en el apogeo de las colas
se habla de un homenaje pícaro ya que
alessandro michelle que firma las
colecciones de gucci declina las creadas
por de navas alia para balenciaga
así pues tenemos una gran casa francesa
de alta costura y una casa de prêt à
porter de marroquinería y de gran
artesanía y ambas han sido completamente
revolucionadas por dos nuevos
diseñadores que tienen un gran diego y
todavía gran visión de la estética
verlos trabajar juntos o no separados en
cualquier caso se citan no solo reaviva
el deseo sino que despiertan nuevos
deseos seguimos queriendo lo único sí
pero no la forma única así que es otra
forma de singularidad realmente estamos
en proceso de declinar valores que han
sido pilares de la acción
- en el campo de la moda y larreta
porter durante mucho tiempo
ya monto en pocas décadas las coladas se
han convertido así en una ventaja
importante para la moda son fácilmente
reconocibles por la letra x que indica
la combinación de las marcas incluso las
marcas jóvenes que están en la brecha es
el caso de alta baja y baja de la trafic
una empresa parisina muy joven que aún
no permite a sus tres socios
treinteañeros ganarse la vida
cada uno de ellos mantuvo su trabajo en
ingeniería derecho y aeronáutica sus
propuestas creativas reciclaje y super
reciclaje los tres comprábamos mucha
ropa y dijimos por qué nos ponemos
tampoco esta ropa debe ser posible
sacarle algo así que lo que hicimos fue
tomar esas prendas de hacerlas y hacer
algo nuevo y luego fue evolucionando con
el tiempo es decir tuvimos la suerte de
poder colaborar con muchas marcas que
confiaron en nosotros
esto significa que muchas marcas tienen
existencias inactivas o defectuosas
por ejemplo en este caso estamos
trabajando en un rodaje para una marca
de trajes de baño llamada apnea y
empezamos con un stock inactivo ya que
era un exceso de existencias y al
empezar con trajes de baño decidimos
darle un giro para hacer algo más
el dandismo el street wear y japón son
sus principales fuentes de inspiración
hoy la tag page ha unido sus fuerzas con
una marca de ropa deportiva comprometida
así que se trata un poco de salvar el
mundo
lo que es salvar el mundo no lo sé pero
reducir nuestro impacto en el medio
ambiente eso es seguro es decir es decir
hemos decidido convertir los residuos en
un recurso de hecho utilizamos
materiales plásticos recorridos entre el
área del mar mediterráneo para fabricar
nuestros trajes de baño un bañador
sólido botellas de plástico recicladas y
principio de las colaboraciones
hoy en día se conviertan en la norma
cuando conocí a la naranja
efecto es genial y nosotros tenemos
camisetas viejas cansados defectuosas
camisetas que ya no vendemos porque son
de colecciones demasiado viejas
y porque en lugar de tirarlas no hacer
algo más con ellas y que corresponda a
nuestros valores que nos hablan ninguno
de ustedes fue a la escuela de moda oa
la escuela de administración no ninguno
de nosotros aprendimos sobre la marcha y
seguimos aprendiendo hoy aprendemos en
youtube y a veces sabemos nuestros
límites aquí por eso tal vez por qué no
volver a la escuela y tal vez entrar en
la moda no se hundía todavía somos
jóvenes no
y las colaboraciones no se distribuyen
ampliamente sino que se lanzan siempre
en series limitadas pero para que
funcionen no basta con un simple
intercambio comercial es necesario
cultivar diálogos culturales